dans la capitale libyenne tripoli la
menace du coronavirus a laissé place à
des rues désertes et des magasins fermés
cela fait plus de dix jours que des
mesures ont été mises en place par les
deux camps rivaux pour contrer l'arrivée
et la propagation du virus
la fermeture du seul aéroport
international à tripoli et les contacts
limités avec l'étranger avait créé chez
certains l'illusion d'un rempart contre
le virus
alors jusqu'à mardi soir la libye
faisait figure d'exception avec zéro
patients déclarés annonçons ce jour du
24 mars 2020 une première contamination
au coronavirus en libye nous insistons
pour que tous les citoyens respectent
les mesures nécessaires prescrites par
le ministère de la santé
1 le centre national de lutte contre les
maladies
l'annnonce de ce premier cas est
particulièrement préoccupante pour ce
pays en guerre où le système de santé
s'est dégradé alors dans la capitale des
agents municipaux désinfecte les rues
mais aussi des magasins pour contrer la
propagation du corona virus la situation
sécuritaire et humanitaire c'est en plus
aggravée depuis le lancement il ya près
d'un an de l'offensive du maréchal aptar
contre tripoli des combats qui ont fait
plus de 1000 morts et cent cinquante
mille déplacés pour se concentrer sur la
lutte contre le coronavirus les deux
camps rivaux avaient accepté une trêve
le 21 mars à l'initiative de plusieurs
pays mais aussi de l'onu une trêve dont
ils s'accusent tous deux de violation